on est en janvier 2001 ça fait bientôt
trois ans que cette histoire a commencé
vous voyez du coup de quoi on va parler
aujourd'hui notamment sont pas ce que
vous avez vu la miniature de la vidéo et
que vous avez lu le titre mais bref on
va parler vous allez m'accompagner pour
ma 20e séances de laser de détatouage
donc pas écouté on y va tout de suite
et comme d'habitude bondés les femmes
[Musique]
je prends pas le même chemin que
d'habitude parce que c'est la grève
c'était la grêle au monde je tourne je
m'assis et la grève au moment où je
diffuse même
[Musique]
je rentre à la maison et j'ai plutôt
plutôt des bonnes nouvelles
je vais vous raconter ça mais je me
mettre au chaud parce que ben j'vais pas
chauffée du coup alors donc plutôt une
très bonne nouvelle mais on va pas
spoiler je vous garde ça pour la fin
comme d'habitude la barre on va
commencer par un petit débrief de la
séance de nouveau une séance sans
pommade anesthésiante pour une raison
assez simple c'est que ça me fait
économiser une heure de mon temps si
vous avez le temps vous faites le et
puis surtout moi on me la met sur place
et du coup j'attends sur place une heure
quel s'agisse pour la simple et bonne
raison que c'est pas facile de se mettre
soi même de la peau mate sur la fesse ça
encore ça va mais le pansement vous
verrez c'est un pansement de particules
est vraiment seul mais tout seul sur la
fesse c'est pas possible donc membres le
fait là bas
habituellement donc j'ai hâte en une
heure sur place je peux rien faire
pendant ce temps là là ça me permet de
gagner une heure donc pas de pommade
d'autant plus qu' il ya quand même de
moins en moins de pigments qui explose
sous la peau de mes fesses c'est quand
même ça a quel plus douloureux donc je
peux m'en passer
après vous avez vu sur certaines zones
le laser passe et ya pas de bruit il se
passe pas grand chose le bruit à je vous
rappelle ans et le pigment qui éclate
donc il ya certaines zones il se passe
rien pas de bruit
[Musique]
donc plus de pigments pas de douleur non
plus à part la légère brûlure du laser
mais qui est vraiment très très
supportable c'est le vraiment
l'explosion du pigment qui qui est le
plus douloureux à d'autres endroits par
contre on a encore un petit borie de pop
corn assez significatif avec la petite
douleur qui va avec
donc il reste du pigment ça confirme que
hama et julie linge parce que vous
connaissez les deux tatoueurs qui
s'étaient relayés autour de mon
postérieur pour me faire ce glorieux
tatouages
là bas ils ont mis la dose de d'encre
donc merci à eux du coup si vous
cherchez des tatoueurs pour vous faire
un tatouage cool parce qu'ils font des
trucs cool et qui va vous survivre par
delà la mort n'hésitez pas à faire appel
à eux je vous remets le lien vers leur
instar respectifs dans la description de
cette vidéo
voilà juste peut-être choisissez mieux
que moi votre motif c'est mon conseil
avant de répondre à la question qui a
été posée dans le titre de cette vidéo
on va faire le petit points habituels
c'est à dire on va faire le petit
comparatif voir un petit peu ce qui
s'est passé pendant pendant ces deux
mois pendant lesquels vous n'avez pas vu
mes fesses et je sais que ça vous
manquait donc voilà la photo juste avant
la dernière séance de 2010 neuf donc du
coup et puis là juste à côté voilà la
photo du tatouage
juste avant la première séance de 2009
donc vous voyez qui s'est encore passé
des choses vous voyez que bain avant
cette séance la d'aujourd'hui il restait
déjà plus grand chose du coup la
question que j'ai posée aux médecins
c'est est ce que par hasard
la séance du jour ce serait pas la
dernière séance alors partant du
principe que si on donne un poisson à
quelqu'un qui a faim il mangera un jour
mais que si on lui apprend à pêcher dit
mangera tous les jours
sauf les jours ou et a pas le temps
d'aller à la pêche par exemple ou n'ya
plus de poisson ou quoi ou tesla
au lieu de répondre directement à cette
question est-ce que c'était ma dernière
séance
je vais vous apprendre mais peut-être et
sans doute même que vous le savez déjà
je vais vous indiquer la façon d'y
répondre vous même il ya une règle
absolue sur youtube quand on fait une
annonce dans le titre et que c'est suivi
d'un point d'interrogation
la réponse est toujours non voilà si ça
avait été la dernière séance aujourd'hui
j'aurais dit la dernière séance point
d'exclamation
si je dis la dernière séance c'est que
non voilà et ben non
donc ça n'est pas la dernière séance
mais c'est peut-être l'avant-dernière
peut-être que la prochaine fois on sera
bon le médecin a pas pu s'avancer il va
falloir se laisser passer encore deux
mois puisque là on était encore sur des
réglages assez costaud donc on va
laisser un le temps à la peau de se
reposer deux le temps aux pigments qui
ont été explosées d'être évacués par les
par les cellules comme d'habitude et
donc dans deux mois il verra la tête que
ça et bah il me dira peut-être genre
passe un coup de laser
cette fois là et puis après au revoir
merci monsieur merci madame ans voire
baba alors ça veut pas dire que la
prochaine fois il restera absolument
rien il ya plusieurs types de traces qui
peuvent me restait à évoquer la
possibilité qui me reste quelques traces
fantôme on avait déjà parlé une fois je
sais pas s'il vous souvenez je vais vous
remettre le lien dans la description les
traces fantôme
c'est en fait c'est la réaction
inflammatoire de l'épiderme qui se
défend contre l'agression du laser ça
produit un certain nombre de substances
dont certaines stimule des cellules de
notre organisme qui s'appelle les
mélanocytes et qui sont notamment un
chargé de fabriquer des pigments comme
ceux qui apparaissent quand on bronze et
du coup on a parfois après coup une
hyperpigmentation donc trop de pigments
inflammatoires donc liée à
l'inflammation et ça veut dire que sur
le tracé du laser c'est à dire le tracé
du tatouage puisque c'est là que ça
passe et là on a comme une petite trace
de bronzage donc j'en ai pas beaucoup
la dernière fois qu'on en avait parlé
gens n'avaient quasiment pas du tout là
j'en ai un petit peu mais de toute façon
il me dit que ça c'est le genre de chose
qui après disparaît avec le temps pas
trop d'inquiétude autres types de traces
qui pourraient rester même si la
prochaine fois c'est la dernière séance
il ya des endroits où la peau a été
abîmé quand même alors c'était avec
l'ancienne technique et donc dans
l'ancien centre notamment au niveau des
yeux schéma si vous souvenez de ces
clubs sont horribles la peau à un peu
morflé donc je suis quand même un petit
peu brûlé à son voilà il restera très
probablement petite trace de type
brûlure qui va s'estomper avec le temps
alors il ya d'autres types on en avait
parlé aussi de traces qui peuvent rester
qui me concerne pas pour le coup qui
sont l inverse de ce qu on a vu tout à
l'heure sur l'hyper pigmentation l'ipo
pigmentation servent pas à ces pigments
ce alors que le laser au lieu de
stimuler les mélanocytes et donc de leur
faire produire du dépigmenter de
bronzage
ils les tuent donc là il ya plus du tout
qu'il ment donc ça fait une trace
blanche ça a priori j'aurais pas
j'aurais pas ça ce que j'aurai en
revanche mais là c'est pas lié au laser
c'est plutôt lié aux tatouages
il ya sûrement des endroits où j'aurai
comme une petite cicatrice vous savez le
tatouage c'est quand même une aiguille
qui est passé de façon répétée au niveau
de la peau donc ça va
des endroits où ça l'est
une petite cicatrice c'est possible que
j'ai ça donc j'aurai peut-être petite
trace fantômes qui devrait disparaître
légères traces de brûlures notamment au
niveau des yeux qui vont sans doute
s'estompe et épicé mini cicatrices bon
c'est encore un petit peu tôt pour en
parler ce que je vous propose c'est de
faire un bilan après la prochaine séance
inchallah la dernière je vais commencer
à faire un outil hands up de tout ça de
combien ça va coûter le temps que ça m'a
pris là et c'est pour parce que
peut-être que la prochaine fois ce sera
l'heure du bilan si vous avez des
questions s'il ya des sujets que j'ai
pas abordé dans tout s'est alors
peut-être regarder les vidéos
précédentes parce que j'ai abordé un
sujet par vidéo pour 1 pour ainsi dire
en tout cas si vous avez des questions
n'hésitez pas à les poser dans les
commentaires ce sera l'occasion la
prochaine fois de faire de faire un
petit bilan croiser les doigts et les
fesses pour moi pour que la prochaine
soit effectivement la dernière sait pas
c'est pas sûr encore je veux pas
m'avancer mais bon là on arrive quand
même gentiment à 3 ans de traitement
donc pourquoi pas écoutez je vais vous
laisser on se retrouve vite
évidemment pour d'autres vidéos d'ici là
prenez soin de vous prenez soin de vos
fesses et prenez soin des autres
mettez vous bien et surtout portez vous
bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]